[Music]
we saw that you were dating and you were
you know you were going through eisa
phase that she's gone dude that's right
how are you still single oh my god who
is she's reentering the dating world
she's dealing with haps oh right she's
dealing with absent you know you're
helping her through her face I'll just
say that it is the thing I always want
to have the whole thing ain't you know
that's rude and yes how are we gonna see
her transform and how are you gonna be
that voice of reason for her between her
and Lawrence Molly tried to warn ISA she
said you know you're not ready for this
life this app life is not your friend
after I tried to tell her girls never
told me but you know that's that's water
on the bridge you know we have made the
decisions that we have made and I think
she's gonna find that like dating is not
as easy as she thought and you know
she's gonna experience it and sometimes
you have to experience things for
yourself to like learn the lesson that
you need to learn everyone's journey
season to Lawrence's journey and trying
to figure out how to reel back from
being hurt ESA's journeying from how to
be in a long-term relationship for last
four years so being single and Molly
trying to do things differently take
things as they come are we about to see
a very mature side of Molly and season
two um a little bit I think Molly is
trying to be mature as best she can
I think we'll probably see some of her
insecurities come out as well so season
two you're gonna see her kind of all I'm
happy to see that Molly is going to
therapy and I say that because we don't
often see that on television
how exciting is it to see that the black
experience is being told in a different
way in season two no I think I think
that's what makes the show really
exciting and fun and fresh last thing we
talked about like homosexuality or like
within the black community we looked at
black women who cheat and that things
that we haven't necessarily seen before
so I think the show is always going to
throw up like a lot and see where it
lands and never tell you a right or
wrong and then you can figure out why
you feel the way you feel you can figure
out where you stand on the issue and
then be challenged one way or another
right and I think you know a lot of a
lot of times exposing the black
community were therapy is something but
it's like just go to church right yeah
right right well they're your dirty
laundry to strangers they don't know Wow
my sense why would I pay for a fake
friend but clearly it's like no girl you
need somebody to talk to you yeah you so
don't got the answers cuz she's going
through her own day and you have to end
this way so let's let's try and get a
professional who has a degree and feel
like they can help or not
[Music]
you